Marcus how does a kid who grew up in
Ventura end up acting in La you have a
really supportive High School Drama
teacher who takes you to a acting class
in Los Angeles and
you have to deal with the fact that you
really
suck and you have to unlearn everything
you thought you knew and you stick to it
and you take the criticism and you grow
from it and you hone your CFT and
eventually your acting coach in La
introduces you to an agent who happens
to be his wife uh and you audition for
them and they take you on and then you
start auditioning for things and if
you're lucky you get to read for a show
created by Steven botko and they hire
you um and it does well and you impress
a guy like Steven botko and he invites
you to join a television
series that's how it happened for me you
know back in the 1600s I don't know how
it works now but um right I mean that's
so so just rewinding of a little bit I
mean ventur is a beautiful town it's
more of like sort of a family
environment yes very much and uh you're
it's what 2 hours away from La just
probably by now traffic-wise I mean it's
normally should be an hour
but there's a lot of there's a lot of
traffic here that it used to not be here
so it's it's I would probably say about
an hour and a half okay so you you were
taking uh drama classes and was that
your plan all along to be an actor no I
thought I wanted to be an
architect I was horrible at math wow and
I couldn't
draw but I was going to be an
architect I saw but I I had a teacher
and her husband was an architect and
they look very fancy to me so I was like
oh okay well to be fancy you go be an
architect um and I was terrible at math
I didn't know you needed that I didn't
know what you needed to be an architect
I just wanted the fancy life um but uh
my Drama teacher was smart enough to say
maybe try this instead I don't know if
that architect stuff's going to work out
so well with your math grades so that's
kind of how that happened um
I like how sorry interrupt but I like
how you said that you didn't know what
you needed to be an architect what do
you think people need to be an actor
that's I mean you drove two hours I
think you
need and this probably is a little bit
unpopular nowadays I think you need
talent um I think you need more than
talent I think you need drive and
ambition and especially in today's
landscape you need to have at least a
base on understanding of the way the
business works and you have to
understand where you fit in um you know
people look at
you casting directors and such they're
looking at your picture to set a role
and if you look like me you're not going
to look like the guy that Chris Pine is
going to play you know what I mean so
you have to understand that you have to
know where you fit and you have to be
able to navigate that
um in a realistic way it doesn't mean
that you can't get to where you want to
go but you do have to be able to operate
within the industry as it is right now
and how you fit into it right now and I
think that sort of realism mixed with
Talent hard work Drive and ambition is
what brings us these people that kind of
come up out of nowhere and break the
molds you know what I
mean right cuz it Doesn't didn't sound
like you had a stage parent that was
like on your back like we're taking you
here okay nobody knew anything I didn't
know anything my Drama teacher didn't
know anything you know I mean I learned
I learned as I went I mean I as a little
kid I uh I thought movies were reality
shows I didn't know what reality shows
were but I thought that Hollywood people
would find somebody really cool and then
they would just follow them around and
that's what a movie was so in a
way I'm this person that came up with
reality TV before it happened why in The
Truman Show yeah in The Truman Show nice
um but no I you know I I thought that's
what that was and then I found out that
you know that was a job that was an
actor and that was a job you could get
um and so I remember saying to my family
yeah I want to be an actor and then
after they got finished
laughing uh it was just something that
was so far out of my reach in their
opinion that became my opinion you know
but then I got to high school my Drama
teacher made it more of a a real
possibility in my head again so I
decided to go for it did you even have
head shot at that time in high school
yeah when they took you down to no no
you know it worked different then you
know
you it's harder now
because there's a lot of stuff when
you're starting out you've got to do on
your own um back in the day you know you
you could find managers and agents who
would
actually promote and and and help sort
of develop a career and that's a much
harder thing to find nowadays so you end
up with places like backstage and and
actor access and you know actors are now
having to find ways to develop their own
careers and start their own stuff um so
yeah I didn't really have pictures or
anything until my agent was like um you
got to have
pictures
so so then they they hooked you up with
someone here in Ventura to take them no
when I once I got to Los Angeles
everything happened in Los Angeles you
know my agent took me to an LA
photographer everything was there
everything happened in La
um back then you had to move to one of
the hubs and you had LA or New York and
you know that's where the career was
that's where the industry was that's
where you needed to be obviously now
it's different you know there's more
hubs first of all um and there's just
more access to things because folks all
over the country all over the world are
making films are finding each other
through the internet and sites like this
um so there's a lot more opportunity to
start now than was then but it's still
pretty exciting to you know be a
16-year-old kid in Los Angeles all the
time was pretty awesome how soon did you
start working after
that I think I got my first gig about a
year
in um I did a play at the L
um and it was at that play that I ran
into um a casting director who was
casting uh she worked for Steven botko
and they asked me to audition for dookie
Hower and so that's how that
happened that was fun once that audition
happened how quickly and how much did
your life change
immediately like immediately
because um you kind of go from like
you're just a face in the crowd you're
just another picture you know um and now
Steven botko you're like his latest find
so now everyone's really interested in
who the hell you are you know what I
mean so it's an immediate switch and
That Was Then you know
now the way the fame celebrity machine
works I'm sure when folks get on shows
nowadays so there's so much more to do
with regard to you know publicity and
and and all of that stuff we did a lot
but nothing compared to what happens now
so you moved down to La of course to be
on the show or okay um and then are you
also taking classes and doing other
things in addition to be on the show or
I had been taking classes on a
consistent basis up until I started the
show at that point I just didn't have
the time time um we were we had like
6:00 a.m. calls and we would work you
know 12 14 hour days and we were working
every day during the week because you
know we were a single camera show so it
was shot similar to a feature um unlike
sitcoms which
are awesome schedule wise it's really a
lot less um but yeah we were just we
were just going and going so my real
training really kind of kicked in when I
started doing the show and working with
these people who are veterans and you
know been doing things for way longer
than I had and uh I think that was a
real big learning process because I was
there on set you got to make it happen
you know what I mean yeah you get takes
but still there's a big difference
between you know acting on a stage in a
class you know that you you paid for um
and being on a set where the time is
equivalent to money and you are spending
money and it's important that things get
done correctly it's a big difference big
big
difference how was it too for you you
know sounds like you're under 20 at this
point and you're in LA and Ventura just
from the short time I've been up here is
beautiful it's a slower pace I'm not
seeing angry drivers on the road like LA
and and I'm just wondering how that was
for you to go from such a nice place to
like this intense town and there's good
parts of LA too but exhilarating was it
cuz you know it is very sort of it's
it's slower and and more calm and
peaceful um but I was born in
Philadelphia so I was born a city kid so
I like being in the city you know and
there there's just just there's just
more there's a tradeoff you know if
you're in Los Angeles you don't necessar
I mean Los Angeles is actually pretty
beautiful city in and of itself um but
the access to that beauty is a lot
harder than in Ventura you want to go to
the beach you drive up to the beach you
park a car you go to the beach here you
got to park and you got to find a thing
you got to pay the guy and you got to
you know there's a lot of stuff before
you can actually just walk out onto the
sand
but you know there's also so much more
available in terms of culture and art
and all of these things whereas in
Ventura you
know not as much right but a beautiful
place here gorgeous gorgeous place
gorgeous place and you know not devoid
of art but it is a different to
different category right you're on the
show for how long dookie Hower I was on
dookie what did we run Four Seasons so I
was there for three I did a gas spot in
the first season and then they brought
me on for the second and then we ran for
three
after so after the show finished what
was your game plan and what did you end
up doing I wanted to just do more I I I
wanted to do film I really wanted to do
film
um there weren't a lot of
things available
that fit what I wanted to
do so that became sort of a a
frustrating thing there was also not a
lot but a little bit of um you do a show
like Doogie um and then you end up with
this iconic character that Neo played
and so everybody sort of
gets for lack of a better term
dogi um so it's like well we don't know
if we want our movie to be about dudy
Hower because you're so known for that
show obviously it's not as bad you know
for those of us that weren't Doogie I
mean Neil Neil what Neil's accomplished
is amazing you know because he
successfully overcame what was an
iconic child star role you know and it
it took a while for people to see past
doie and see Neil the talent that He is
um but that was a little bit of you know
struggle I did a lot of stuff in TV I
did a lot of Pilots um that didn't go I
read for a lot of Pilots that did go um
but uh ultimately I just kind of wanted
to continue acting I don't know that I
had a game plan per se I just was one of
those actors that depended on on the
representation um and it took me a while
to figure out that if I wanted to get
something done that I needed to take be
more proactive take matters into my own
hands um and that took a while took a
while to figure that out this is before
sort of web series and social media and
all that okay yeah this is way before
that right so you you're still staying
in LA and were there any points where
you wanted to come back to Ventura and
you said I'm I'm done with this or no no
I always knew that I wanted to be
working in this business ever since I
was a little kid even though I got
laughed at but you know I just I just
knew that there had to be a way to
maneuver within this industry um and I
think the problem that I had as an actor
was that I
was I kept myself in a position of not
knowing things you know I I was I was a
an actor who sat by the
phone and waited for the call and got
upset because the call didn't come and
that's no one's fault but mine you know
what I mean you have there's a great one
of my favorite shows is a taxi love taxi
so great so good there's a line in taxi
where Alex is talking to Bobby who's the
actor in the show and and and Bobby's so
upset and he's so frustrated and he gave
himself this amount of time to make it
New York and Alex says to him listen all
I know is that if you want a job you got
to go find a line to stand in you can't
just sit around complaining um and
that's what I hadn't done at that time I
I was still sitting around and
complaining like Bobby I had to figure
out where that line was and how to go
stand in it and and and change things
and that's how I landed on screenwriting
during that time what was some of the
best advice aside from that line in taxi
that's excellent love the show um and
what was some of the worst advice that
you got you don't have to tell you names
but like what were some things that were
just so cliche and it it's just like no
this is like a power speech that's not
going to go anywhere and then some stuff
that was like wow that's really
interesting that like in that time for a
yeah when that sort of like I mean I
want to say it's maybe more of a dip it
sounds like and then you came out of a
dip definitely a
uh cuz some people are full of
well-intentioned advice and it just just
like no that's not going to work but
then others have interesting points you
know
what the best piece of advice I got
during that
time was from my girlfriend at the time
and she
said you should just write a movie
and then sell it to a
studio and then you can find out how it
all really
works and that's why I wrote my first
script and that was a really great piece
of
advice
um and I guess because of me thinking of
it that simply I was able to sell my
first scripts like maybe that's why I
don't know I mean it's not it's
obviously not that easy but in my head
it was and so I wrote this thing and we
got it out and
done um that was probably the best
piece worst
piece I don't know I don't know I mean
there were there were there were there
were bad things said to me weren't
necessarily advice like nobody ever said
you know go home kid you bother me but I
don't know if I got a piece of bad
advice but I did get that I did get that
advice and I decided to
write and we that we sold that script to
Columbia from the time that she told you
that how did how much time went by when
you started writing that script next day
next day wow this is before Starbucks or
no Starbucks was around wow did the
World exists before Starbucks there
probably was Starbucks but I don't drink
coffee so oh you don't okay yeah I can't
I'm one of those weirdos that doesn't so
so so you where did you start writing
the script cuz there was I had a friend
who was an aspiring writer and he had
final
draft so I went to him and I said hey
man I want to write a script and he was
like you want to what I said just
give me the final draft show me how it
works he's like that's not how final
draft works I was like dude whatever
just you know I just just show me how it
works so he taught me how it works he's
like you just do that and hit the tab
and then write the thing like all right
what are you going to write I don't know
I just want to write a script write a
script well you didn't have an
idea floating around no no I was like
I'm just going to write
one read them all my life can't be that
hard right hard but I just figured just
write a script just start like what what
am I doing I'm sitting here I'm staring
at a phone that doesn't ring you know
phone's not going anywhere I'm not going
anywhere I could be sitting here a year
from now and me and my phone can be
hanging out together or I can be sitting
here a year from now me and my phone can
be hanging out with a script that I
wrote so I started writing and um I was
like I just want to figure out something
that would work and at the time it was
like uh you had all these uh like U it
was like the teen stuff was hot so this
is like post scream this is like Cruel
Intentions and you know I Know What You
Did Last Summer when the lights went off
in Georgia or whatever uh so I was like
all right so they're making this stuff
and everything was in high school so I
was like okay I'll put something in
college all right what's the story they
all seem to be Horrors and thrillers
okay oh oh
yeah so I started looking at films that
were really really popular like in the
80s take that story that basic
idea set it in college
now now I got a thing that's a proven
track record that works but then I got
this other thing and it's new and it's
fresh and it's different and that became
the first script that became I would die
for you was about a guy going to Santa
Barbara UC Santa Barbara and had a
girlfriend and life was good and a buddy
of his in his hometown was getting
married so he goes back to his hometown
for the wedding without his girlfriend
cuz she was off doing whatever and uh he
runs into his ex-girlfriend from high
school and she she and he end
up you know and uh he leaves he says you
know it's a mistake whatever it's good
to see you goes back to his life and you
see Santa Barbara turns around there's
the
ex-girlfriend hey how are you what's up
is this your girlfriend oh my God she's
so great now the girlfriend loves the
ex-girlfriend and he's in hell and that
became it became I would die for you and
uh Columbia bought that up we had a good
time with it it was fun how long did it
take you to write
it I hate this
question sorry no it's good it's good
it's good
uh three weeks three weeks wow yeah how
many drafts did you
do before I sold it
mhm three maybe
four it wasn't it wasn't a lot
going to do a lot of drafts are you
working as an actor at this time or you
have an odd job or you no no no I'm um
I'm I've now sort of moved into the
whole like film making scenario so um a
buddy of mine named James ltin got
together and we created a production
company and we're working on films that
I write and direct and star in and we
shot our first one this is now back in
April and now we're working on our
second Thriller coming out in October
um and we've got plans for the third
film we want to shoot next
spring um so yeah that's that's that's
where I'm at now um at that time though
like so how did you get access to pitch
Columbia like oh oh oh oh yeah okay
sorry problem then yes I was still sort
of making a the living as an actor you
know and you know I there by that time I
had done murder one and NYPD Blue so
there were like really healthy residuals
floating around um like had residual for
murder one one year not a year was like
one day I just went there was a residual
of like $15,000 from was like I bought a
car it was great um so that was where
that was at that time um and I had a
friend who was a comedian and he had a
buddy who was a manager a literary
manager and I called my comedian friend
up his name is Amed Amed
Amed and he says hey man I got the
script man I'm I think it's really good
I want to sell it he's like you should
call Brian dude Brian's a manager now
you should call him up give me your
script see what you can do I like okay
so I sent it to Brian and Brian's like
so what do you want to do I was like
dude I don't care like I don't care if
they want to turn into pigs on the moon
it'll be pigs on the moon I don't care I
just want to sell a thing I I W find out
how it works cuz nobody will tell me how
it works this whole whole thing so I can
find out how everything works he's like
all right cool so he sat he read it gave
me some notes went back and forth
through the notes um and so then once he
was happy with it he decided to do like
a
soft what do they call it not Pitch when
the agents and managers they send it out
I don't know soft send out I don't know
it's they have a name for it I can't
remember but he sent it out to a few
people as opposed to like a
blanket thing you know you know cuz
usually you know you you go wide with it
you send it out to all the studios and
all the production companies and you see
who bites so he was like I'm going to
send it out to people I know first see
what they think see how it plays and
then we'll go bigger I was like all
right cool so at the time there was a
production company I cannot remember the
name of the production company they had
a deal at Warner Brothers and the
executive at the production company was
Channing dunie and Channing is actually
now I believe she's the head of drama at
ABC now um but she read it and she was
like this good I like this I want to go
out with it and she did the same thing
Brian did she was like I'm not going to
go why I'm just going to I got a friend
I to see how it plays so she sent it to
a woman named Carrie Richmond and Carrie
was an executive at Columbia at Sony so
she took it to Carrie and Carrie read it
and Carrie was
like I like it it's
good has anybody else seen it she's like
no nobody's seen it not yet tell you
what we're going to make a preemptive
thing we make an option and let's do it
wow and we did it and that's how the
first one happened see I didn't want to
be vague about it that's how it actually
happened thank you for the detail that's
how it actually happened so it wasn't
like you know there wasn't like a big
sort of what do they call it
uh do mackina it wasn't like a big thing
that just sort of like landed you know
CA didn't just show up and
go that didn't happen it was a little
manager and he knew some folks and they
knew some folks and then everybody loved
the script it all came back to we like
this script um and as I've continued
I've realized
it all comes down to that it all comes
down
to the words on these pieces of paper we
dig those so let's see what we can do
that's what it's always come down to in
my experience
so Marcus are you an employee a
freelancer or a business
owner I'm all of those things
actually um I am an employee of James
langin who is all also
my investor and producing partner and
White Rabbit
entertainment um so I'm a business owner
with him because we own that business
together and I'm a freelancer in the
sense that I make my own
films so I'm all free okay did you
always think of yourself in that light
no not at all not at all I didn't want
to do any of this stuff are you kidding
me I just wanted to be an actor I just
wanted to show up on set and like you
know drink fancy water and say words
that's all I ever wanted to do but you
know in order to do that sometimes you
got to do some other stuff so I got into
writing because I got frustrated as an
actor and I wanted to learn more about
how the business worked and I got into
directing purely out of
necessity pure necessity I had a
location that was offered to me to shoot
in for free to do a short
and uh what the hell was it it's it's
called Bank of Venice it's a restaurant
in Venice
California which is town that I love and
uh Thomas Elliott was a friend he's the
owner he was a friend of my buddy Jason
teag and I had asked Jason if he could
ask Tom if I could shoot in Bank of
Venice during their off hours and I was
putting a short together for nothing and
uh Jason asked Tom and I talked to Tom
and Tom was like when we shut down you
can shoot and you can be there till
about 5: in the
morning and you don't have to pay me I
was like okay great awesome but my uh my
director at the time wasn't able to make
that that time frame um she was out of
town at the time and I needed to take
advantage of this
opportunity um so I I told her I was
just going to do it um and hope for the
best and it's unfortunate she I really
did want to work with her she's amazing
um but I just it was in front of me I
had to take it and I took it um that's
how I shot my first short as as a
director it's
crazy of all the scripts you've written
which one has been the one that's the
most close to you most personal
story a lot of them
okay I try to write from a place of of
You Know
Myself uh just because I find it's just
the words end up on the page the most
honest
that way um this is now is a very
personal
story um if I had known I was a genius
was a very personal story and this is
now sort of a continuation of that
um and and then there's a piece I have
called
unrequited um that um is a very personal
story as well it's very much
about finally growing
up me finally growing up not being
uh a douchebag is what it is
about is it easier to commit to a
project that's really personal or is it
in some ways almost really uncomfortable
and it's easy to push something to the
back burner because you're like you know
what maybe we shouldn't put that out
there or maybe that's too much I'm too
open in this no I I think it's I think
it's easier to go personal for me
um the back burner is only reserved for
things that I don't have the money to
make
yet if I had the funding I'd make them
all I'd just go right down the line and
just shoot all of them um and some
things aren't personal at all some
things are just like stories or like
there's like a topical issue that you
know I I find and I want to write toward
that or whatever um but no I I would
rather I'd rather put it all out there
and be proud of it because it's what I
wanted to do um than the opposite i' I'd
rather I'd rather be true to what it is
I want to say and the things I want to
say about life and love and
relationships and all of that stuff so
no I don't I don't I don't I don't shy
from that is it almost like therapy or
do you feel like you've been in like a
few years of therapy once you finish it
God the reason I haven't murdered people
is because I write these
scripts it's complet yeah it's totally
it's totally therapy especially
unrequited um unrequited
is it's essentially the story of how I
got
past what was in completely unhealthy uh
infatuation to find
and fall for the woman that is now my
wife oh nice um and I had to do that in
order to do that I had to grow up
because my wife is a woman she's not a
girl she's a great woman and I needed
to I needed to
be not just some dude tooling around in
Venice being a jackass you know I needed
to be a guy I need to be I need to grow
up and that's that's what that was
about
and all of the characters in unrequited
are based on actual people from my life
without
exception
so that one
and this is
now in which all the characters are
really just slices of myself so those
two are probably the most
personal of the scripts that I've
written to date how is it to see that on
screen when there's like maybe there's a
major issue you're working on and you
put it in a script because you believe
in being honest with what you're writing
and then you you see it played out
whether it's your character or it's
interesting
because I feel like when I'm writing all
of that stuff comes out and I go through
the sort of turmoil of it as I'm
writing um you know once it's in the
process of editing and I'm actually
watching it then it's just okay well
this is the best take and this is the
cut and this is that and you know this
is the one that's got the most
vulnerability and this is the one should
it's got the most emotion let's go here
let's go there it's very odd I I I guess
I tend to
compartmentalize pretty well um once I
get to that point it's the writing of it
where the work comes in like you sit
there and you're staring at the page and
you read it back you're like oh I guess
you did just write
that what are you going to do you keep
it on the page you hit delete what are
you going to do and so all right so you
got to struggle with that and just keep
writing but once it's written for me for
my films once it's
written that's it sorry
buddy shouldn't you know people say all
the time with writers you know it's like
I tell people all the time I am a thief
I steal from life all the time if you
say something interesting or horrible I
will steal it I will put it in the
script
so be better around me cuz I will steal
I will completely steal and it's funny
because like I love to take these
character characters that are you know
broken make bad decisions because of the
conflict and my wife she's very much
like you know she loves like bad guys
versus you know good guy versus bad guy
good guy overcomes you know so I will
tell her these stories and she'll just
be
like these people of yours they make
horrible decisions and I I know honey
that's I know that's that's the point I
want you know like they got to make bad
decisions to make good decisions she's
just
like I love you I support you no matter
what but these characters of yours H
horrible
decisions so it's kind of
funny well they say was even writing
villains you know they have reasons that
seem perfectly Justified to them why
they do what they do and it it it's not
they don't maybe think that they're bad
right one of the best pieces of advice I
I got that served me as a writer but it
was actually acting advice this came
from Cliff Osman uh was my acting coach
and he
said he said he had never seen a decent
portrayal of
Hitler
because the the person so vilified by
society that no actor had ever played
him from a true place he was always a
villain and he said said you know who
didn't think Hitler was a villain Hitler
Hitler didn't think he was a Villain at
all Hitler thought he was doing amazing
things for this race of people and he
said because of that you don't get a
real honest betrayal he said you
cannot judge your
character in fact you have to think of
yourself as your character's attorney oh
wow you have to plead your case or the
case of the character to the audience
you can't do that if you're judging the
character um and I took that with acting
and I also took that into my writing as
well you know everybody is coming from a
place where they think they're doing the
right thing right you know
so
that's I think that's really important
actually when you're developing
characters there a minute you judge a
character you've got a
two-dimensional character you know
you've got a
flat you know it's like oh okay I know
this guy's story he's the bad guy or
he's the good guy whatever it is even
good characters do bad things and right
think they're Justified for it and
that's the thing it's that the
complexity of life you know no one's all
bad or all
good have you ever said no to a
role
yes
why I'm glad I'm amusing you what was
the
reason if you without naming anyone's
name what was the reason uh there is a
very very very very very well-known and
well-respected
film by a very very very well-known and
director that was brought to me while I
was working on doy
Hower um and the
role was a lead role that was ultimately
played by a very very very very famous
and well-respected
actor/
rapper
um and I read the first few pages of the
script and it
was I couldn't I couldn't relate to it
it wasn't the world that I knew it
wasn't anything I felt I could bring any
justice to listen I grew up in Philly
yes but I grew up in Philly listening to
big band and swing music from the 30s
and 40s I grew up watching old movies
like The Thin Man and people like
Humphrey Bogart and Edward G Robinson I
grew up watching Woody Allen movies you
know this movie was set in South Central
Los Angeles and it was
Hardcore and I know I have this hair and
I know I'm not the lightest cat on the
planet terms of my skin but I just it
couldn't it did not speak to me it just
didn't speak to me I'm I'm a I'm a weird
bird man I'm just a different dude and I
said no and the film became incredibly
successful iconic it launched the the
careers of just about everybody who was
in it including the
directors
um and I don't regret
it I'm happy that everybody sort of blew
up from it but I wouldn't I would have
been horrible I would have been horrible
in that cuz it's just not my world and I
left Philly and moved to Ventura and
grew up with Surfers so I'm not I'm the
weirdest dreadlock black guy on the
planet I you know the stuff I'm supposed
to like I don't like the stuff I do like
is weird I'm just weird I'm
not I am
uncastable no one's looking for me you
know what I mean no one's looking for
the black guy with dreads who's really
big who likes Woody Allen movies and big
band music nobody's looking for that
dude nobody so I create things on on my
own but yes I did I did say no to that
film
and I'm sorry you said no because you
felt you just couldn't resonate with the
character yeah mhm there's nothing you
know listen when it comes to that kind
of stuff to me you can be Lawrence
Olivier you can have that type of
talent um gosh what's the
age range for film courage have I said a
name people aren't going to know who
that
is I well my ego would love to think
it's a wide demographic but um I I think
people know oliv yeah well they can look
them up if they we one of the greatest
actors in the history of the world uh
you you could be that you could have
that um and you could be sitting next to
a guy who grew up in Englewood and knew
a guy who is exactly like the guy in the
script and he's going to get it
because there's an authenticity to that
you know
and
authenticity in a lot of ways can Trump
just Talent do you know what I mean
there's just something real and tangible
to it and I don't know you know this was
this was a really hardcore film it was
about gangs and it was about you know
young black men who were fighting
against a system that was working
against them on a consistent basis on
the streets police you know all of that
and I'm not see sitting here saying that
I've had this like Rosy peachy life and
you know police send me chocolates and
whatnot but I didn't live that
life and I know guys that
have and if you've lived
it there's just intrinsically there's
something that you know about it I'm not
going to know you know what I mean I
don't know if that makes sense but
there's just something real about that
that you can't
touch um when I did Doogie my character
was a gang member um he was a gang
member looking to get out and he was
slowly actually wasn't very slow at all
I mean when they brought me back to the
show they yanked me out of that really
quickly um and I think a lot of that had
to do with me and who I was as they got
to know me as a person and my character
you know kind of got pulled away from
that gang stuff as soon as possible
because there was just
something there was something different
about having to live that life and I
have the utmost respect for people who
come from that and rise and grow and and
create and and and are
successful and
there is the word
transcend that life because it's
important and it's
needed
um I'm just not that guy you know how
long did it take you to make that
decision not very long when you were
presented with the offer I think I read
Ted in pages and I called my agent I
said it's not something I can do right
away yeah wow yeah you didn't even give
it like 24 hours you just said I just
know instinctively yes no I mean when
you know for me you know when you know
you know I mean I could have gone in
there and wasted everybody's time you
know I could have walked in be like yeah
what's up I'm like I'm terrible at that
stuff I don't you know I don't even
listen to rap music I don't I
don't I don't like it I get it I
understand I get that it's it's a whole
you know like uh what's the word it's
like a whole lifestyle hip-hop and it's
like it's an empire in and of itself and
it's transcended and it's worldwide and
everybody I know people that only listen
to hip hop right I couldn't tell you who
is anybody I know that I know Nicki
Minaj uh but I haven't heard a song I
know who she is I know she doesn't like
Mariah Carey I know that like I know
like I know the I know like all the all
the beefs I've heard like there's a guy
Drake and he doesn't like another guy
and they're angry at each other so they
rap at each other or something I don't
know the songs but you know I'm not dead
I'm on the Twitter I know what's
happening but I don't and when I do hear
the songs I did did I don't know I don't
know I it just doesn't resonate with
me right I like I like you know I like
old school jazz
and and metal and I'm a weird dude man a
weird
dude sorry
sorry I just you know I can't I just
like what I like man do you have a hard
time booking acting work no because I'm
not trying
to
um when I was yes very much so you know
like I said I'm not I'm
uncastable I'm
not you look at me and you get a very
clear idea a of what I should be doing
um and then I go and ruin it by opening
my mouth and I start talking and it's
not it doesn't it doesn't fit and and I
get it I'm not I'm not an easy I'm sure
my agents and managers God bless them
you guys are awesome but I'm I can't be
an an easy person to um represent as an
actor because I have really eclectic
taste
that do not match what I look like and
that's part of the game you know like I
was saying before it's like you have to
know where you fit
in and it's weird for me cuz I know what
I look like but I don't know a Jamaican
accent and I don't smoke
weed
and uh I don't know an African accent I
know I'm super dark but I I've never
been to Africa I don't know how that
works
I'm a guy who grew up watching Winnie
Allen movies you know and that's the
thing I you know sit me at a dinner
table with intelligent
folk great meal and bottle of wine and
we can talk philosophy all
night that's great like I'm that guy no
one's looking for that guy to look like
me you know what I'm saying like that's
not the guy I don't it's not no one's s
so so I started creating and I would
just I would just put myself in that
position um because that's what's true
to
me despite what I look like was that
something that came you know how people
can't always see how others see them
they just know themselves they know they
what they like right would do you
remember when people started saying wow
I don't really see you in this light or
or you should be more this well it was
immediate it was IM mediate wasn't it
didn't take folks long to go what the
hell's wrong with you um I was spoiled
in my in my um acting classes because my
acting coach gave me like everything I
mean I was doing scenes from carnal
knowledge and and and Midnight Cowboy
and the Godfather so the material was
Stellar you know what I mean um and
that's what I trained on in acting class
so when I got out and I would audition
you know for like thug number
four
um it wasn't the same caliber as
Midnight Cowboy it wasn't quite the same
um and there were there were just
nuances and things that that I had
learned um especially after working with
Steven botko and and his incredible
writing staff um I was I was I was I was
very fortunate as a young tyke because I
got to work with incredibly talented
writers and Incredibly talented
directors and people who like were at
the top of their game um and for
whatever reason said
okay you come play with us um and that's
a rare it's a rare find it's a rare
thing so as I got older and I got past
that um it it became increasingly harder
to find that again um because you know
I I don't know I
just I I I I come from a different place
myself and it doesn't always sync up
with how I look and so that made the
whole auditioning process a little
bit difficult not just for me but for my
Representatives too I felt better
platform Marcus how many screenplays
have you
[Laughter]
written a
lot um films or or television or just or
both or a total of just yeah whatever
could be completed yeah probably around
50 50 okay yeah how many scripts have
you sold oh God three three okay okay
what do you do you think it is about
those three versus the other whatever
47 well
not it's a very good question what is it
about those three I think it's probably
access you know you don't always write
what folks are looking
for you don't always write what folks
are looking for from
you and folks aren't always looking to
read
anything you know I
mean when we did I would die for
you um you know people were the town was
hungry for like what can I put Jennifer
Love huitt in and what can I put Ryan
philippy in and like you know all those
people they were hungry for that stuff
and I wrote something that fit that and
so I was like ah yes great it was a fit
it made sense um when I did genius it
was an independent film um much more
internally generated and we worked
really hard to get funding to get that
set up and made and the the production
company that came on board you know it
was part of a slate and they were
putting their slate together and we were
fortunate enough to have um William
Morris involved in the film and the
amazing amazing amazing brilliant
Cassian elways uh involved and whoy
Goldberg and Sharon Stone and all made
sense
um uh but you know the other things that
I do these films that I'm making on my
own you know I haven't even attempted to
sell them or or put them out or
distribute them in any way because I
want to keep them for myself so I can
make them you know um so so it's a
mixture of a lot of different things
there are things that I keep to myself
because I want to make them myself and
then there's other things that are just
out um and it's just not no one's really
into it right now it's nature of the
Beast so there's an EB and flow it
sounds like there's kind of like
the rest you know I'm thinking of Simon
and gar
song I'm sorry so cliche but yeah just
there's an e there's an e okay there's
an EB like EB and Flo sort of says like
oh there's an e and then there's a
there's an
EB a little bit of flow mostly e it's
mostly it's mostly e and and and it's
your job to create the flow that's what
I think you know I think that the best
thing a writer can do is to keep writing
um and then figuring out where that
writing fits in the marketplace how
you're going to get it out there who
you're going to take it to because you
have to be smart you have to know what
people are looking for you know and
that's a very difficult thing to do you
know you could write something great
they're just not looking for it you know
what I mean like television is a lot
like that you know
television television is programmed I
was told this by a television executive
television is programmed not by what
what's necessarily good
but what they
need so if you've got a really sort of
poignant half hour dramy that's really
really good but what they need is a
silly comedy to come after Modern
Family you know because that has to do
with business see that's the thing
that's the thing that's so difficult
about this business is people for forget
about the business part you know there
are companies involved in fees paid to
networks for these shows and you know
you know those commercials that you see
in between the shows they factor in
because of the show like every you know
it's not just this is brilliant it's
like okay well is Ty cool with this too
like you know can we run Audi
commercials here cuz it's it's all you
know so there's a lot of different
factors that have absolutely nothing to
do with your script um that go into your
script going wherever it's going to go
are you leaning more toward television
in you're writing no no I've written a
lot of Television I love television I
watch more television than I watch films
do you okay I do I really do um I love
television I love Doctor Who oh so good
but no I I I focus in in in film I focus
on features I think that sort
of I think that's where my best work
lives is in features and it's also the
best way I think I
can express myself uh creatively and so
what I look for is Ways and Means to you
know find funding and finance ing for
these small little films and I've been
fortunate enough that I've been able to
do them for incredibly small budgets
because I don't really have a lot of
characters in my in my films um because
they're just stories they're just really
simple stories about people and their
relationships and it it it it it it
shouldn't cost $20
million to tell a story about you know
four people that are trying to figure
out life and that's kind of the stuff I
I really dig so when you're writing and
you're trying to keep an idea of keeping
cost down are there times when it be
like you know what uh let me change that
to one room of a an apartment versus
someone's office building because you're
thinking of I don't do that you don't do
that okay I just want to write a
story um I think it's I can I think it
can be hurtful to your story to do that
um because you just want to tell a good
story
now obviously if you've got things at
your disposal you want to write towards
those things if you can and still tell a
good story but I think story still has
to be key because if you've got an old
abandoned warehouse that you can shoot
in for nothing that's
awesome but if you just shoot a crap
story in an old B Warehouse because you
have it for free you're going to have a
crap movie so you still have to create a
really good story um the the piece that
we're working on now happens mostly in
one house um but it's a thriller and
it's a psychological Thriller and
there's all kinds of things that are
happening in characters are turning and
changing and you don't know who did what
to who and where and why
um and it as I was was writing it and
reading it back it just became a a
compelling story and you know when
you're doing that a lot of times it ends
up reading like a play um because you're
not moving around to so many different
locations but that wasn't written to be
in one
location it was written and it happened
to be in one location I would rather
write a story first and then you know
compact for Budget or whatever later if
that makes sense do you think that
storytelling is as prevalent and as rich
as it once was maybe no I mean taxi just
think about just the characters taxi
episodes that are better than most
movies amazing you know what I mean this
is you know what taxi probably had a
profound effect on how I write you know
what I mean because it's just so
good God and everyone's so flawed in
their own way but they're still likable
and you don't need but see that's what
I'm saying those stories those people
they're just people in a cab garage and
you don't really need to go to a whole
lot of places because the characters
were so strong you know I'm listen there
are stories out there that are fantastic
and there are people out there that are
making wonderful films um both big and
small but I think that we have become a
very sort of franchise motivated
industry because you know a lot of money
is being spent on a lot of films and
that money's got to come from somewhere
and it's got to get made
back and you know you can't you can't
make $2 billion off of a movie that only
cost $10 million you know what I mean um
so there's a again that's all business
that's all like corporate strategy and
you know industry stuff that some of it
has to do with storytelling some of it
doesn't
but I don't know man I think
uh I think we might be in a place where
story is going to become the
only affordable special effect here
pretty
soon you know in the' 40s you know when
the studios own
theaters um there there was like this
sort of cultural generational shift and
everything started to change in the 50s
and so what Hollywood was morphed into
something else um and so all of
these new filmmakers kind of came up out
of nowhere independent guys like you
know cassavetes and you know they made
these films that weren't as expensive
but they were more authentic and real
and they were gritty and they were about
characters and we got these amazing
actors that came out of that like Dennis
Hopper and Jack Nicholson um and then
Hollywood saw what was
happening and found ways to Market it
correctly and turn it into an Empire and
it became great again you know and then
I think what's happening now is is these
movies are they're they're either
enormous or they're tiny you know
there's no sort of midlevel movie
anymore you know they're still out there
but you know they're sort of few and far
between and I think what ends up
happening is you spend so much money on
so much stuff and glitter and the films
they do well but they don't always do
well enough you know but the thing
that's always a
affordable is
story you know story doesn't cost a lot
you just have to have one and you have
to put it down on paper and you have to
be true to the script you have to film
it well and
that I think will become a
very
popular
commodity a wonderful special effect for
film is having a great story she have
these filmmakers now they don't have the
money they don't have the money for
green screens and special effects and
you know robots flying in the sky you
know these guys that are coming out of
everywhere all these different little
pockets in the world they just have a
passion for telling these stories and
and making film there's a lot of really
great ones out there and that's their
special effect it's story that's how
they're gaining Their audience so to me
that's that's the big special effect
that's the big upand cominging special
effect in the film world is story what
about for serialized content cuz before
it was just sitcoms or you know weekly
um you know hour-long dramas maybe but
now people are doing this binge viewing
and it just seems like it's taking over
in some sense I think it's great I mean
it's great and again I love television
you know so it is kind of a cool thing
to be able to see and entire season you
know in the course of an evening you
know to to watch an entire you know
thing play out I I I I think it's great
but again it's only great if the story
is great you know I mean for the longest
time I'm a perfect example in just how I
view things personally I did not watch
The Walking Dead forever because I have
a problem with
zombies in stories
to me it's it's a dumb uh a zombie is an
idiot it's a dumb thing it doesn't it
just so you shoot it and that's it I
understand there's a lot of them but
then that just becomes redundant so I
don't see how it's a good story because
zombie is not a compelling villain to me
because it's a it's a dumb nothing so
it's not a compelling villain so you're
like oh my you got to see The Walking
Dead I was like yeah okay so what
happens the zombies come and then they
kill the Zombies awesome fantastic
that's good I'll pass and I finally
watched
it and it's an amazing story about
survival in
Desolation it's not about the zombies
you know and that's why it's so good
because it's amazing Stories and
wonderful
characters to watch that play out over
the course of a full season and the
serialized drama or to watch it unfold
you know in a film whether you're
watching it on your phone or on an
airplane or in a huge IMAX it's great
everybody loves a great story you know
you know when people talk about moments
in their lives they talk about the story
of what happened you know it's like how
did you get engaged oh it's a great
story that's what they tell you they
don't just go well here's the ring I got
engaged everybody's interested in the
story of it how did it happen like what
you know you go over to someone's house
and they've got something sitting on the
bookshelf it's like how'd you get that
oh it's a great story and that's what we
love we that's what we look for that's
what we want you know so yeah you know
have the Spacemen fly around and shoot
lasers at the Death Star or whatever
just tell a good story while you're
doing it it's the most important special
effect to me story
Marcus I was going through the um AFM
Twitter and I just found this article
that's 13 frequently used phrases that
make you sound like a Hollywood rookie
by Stephanie Palmer and it's a funny
article but there there's some really
interesting stuff in here that I
actually wouldn't know or have known
that it would make someone sound like a
rookie so number one 13 phrases to avoid
she writes High concept and I'm just
wondering what your thoughts are I'm
just doing you know cuz I I know you'll
have something interesting to say she
says if your idea is high concept it's
obvious VI it's not if it's not saying
it won't
help um we've had a lot of interest
which
means to a decision maker this is code
for lots of people have read it but none
of them have liked it enough to get
involved um with the right cast dot dot
dot everyone knows that basically um
this is a very unique project which
means it's a red flag if it's Unique you
haven't done enough research to
understand understand the J genre excuse
me um there's another one that's good oh
it has it's with a message meaning when
you're highlighting that there is a
message this means that you're focused
primarily on teaching the audience a
lesson instead of telling a great story
so I just just your thoughts on some of
these oh and wait one last one sorry
I've been working on this film for 11
years she says you're committed okay
possibly inapp
so we're having fun with it but but how
much truth do you do you hear in some of
this and and you know I
think God bless everybody uh you
know these
articles I take them all with a grain of
salt
because I there's no Road I mean to say
you know these things are going to make
you look like is to indicate that okay
these are the things that you do
correctly and if you do these things
correctly then things will go the right
way and there is no correct the only
correct is like someone writing you a
check and that can happen no matter what
you say you can say this is a really
unique story and someone can say I agree
with you and then they write you a check
which makes that completely null and
void you can say we've had a lot of
interest and someone can say well let me
look at it I'm interested and then they
write a check which makes that saying
null and
void you can't
say the right thing to the wrong person
I think that's the real only
thing you can't say the right thing to
the wrong
person and you can't say the wrong to
the right
person and I think that means that if
it's not going to work for somebody you
can't make it work for somebody you know
I don't think how you say something if
it's coming from a place of Truth in you
is going to make the difference like if
you've got an incredible script and
you've got like a really good set of
whatever you're supposed to have behind
it but you use one of these phrases
someone who really is in love with your
project isn't going to say God I love
this script and he's got so much great
energy and I really want to work with
this person but he used a rookie term H
nah I better not cuz they used a rookie
term nobody's going to do that you know
what I mean like you either find the
people who are your tribe you find the
people that dig what it is that you're
looking to
do or you don't and you know in that
point you either decide I'm just going
to keep looking or you throw in a towel
but I don't think it comes down to say
this or that or I don't know maybe it
does I who knows I don't know but I just
I just think if you're coming from a
real
place and and you're putting your best
work out there you just got to keep
pushing until you find the right person
you
know you said something a moment ago
find your tribe as someone who may have
felt like an outsider and I only say
this because I've felt like one my
entire life so how do you find your
tribe because there's a there's a
tendency to want to glob on to I'm not
even sure that's a word but you want to
like you know fit in with this group
because you think then that's going to
take you where you need to go but it's
not really a fit how do you know what
your tribe is you
don't you just don't just do what you
love man it's all you can do all you can
do is do what you want to do that's how
you find them who those people are going
to be no
idea but you just have to do what you do
if you do what they do then you're
chasing their tribe and they're not
necessarily your tribe so you're just
chasing after people like you know
people pleasing which is something I've
had big problem with in the past you
can't do that it's not it's not good for
you and it's not good for them you're
really wasting everybody's time when
you're trying to please everybody you
know what I mean I think I think you
just have to do what you
do do you as the kids say right you know
well that's interesting why isn't it
good for them cuz I can see why it
wouldn't be good for the individual
trying to be the people pleaser right
eventually you'll excuse me let them
down and they'll get mad at you right or
whatever but why why not for them why
why should I care about people pleasing
why why does it hurt the group that
you're why does it hurt the group you're
trying to please cuz eventually you
can't keep that up it's a lie so you're
basically telling a a bunch of people
that they can depend on you to do what
they want it's not what you want you're
going to crack
eventually and it's going to be a waste
of their time and your time right so why
do it who cares you don't you just have
to love what you
love There's 7 billion people on the
planet I guarantee at least three of
them love what you love that's all you
really need you just need to find three
other people that like what you like
you're good you're fine and they're out
there you just have to do what you do
and just follow that the truer you can
be to
yourself and what you dig the better I
think for everybody because this stuff's
hard it's not easy to make movies and
all of this stuff you might as well love
it because if you're going to do hard
stuff do hard stuff they're going to pay
you tons of money for you know what I
mean go do hard stuff and I don't know
do math or something I don't know
architecture architecture go be an
architect that's hard but you know
they'll pay you a lot of money up front
it's better I think you just have to you
have to do you have to do this cuz you
love it cuz it's burning in you and then
you find the other people so let's take
an example of someone trying to be a
people pleaser as an actor or filmmaker
and then another way to not do that but
still be
Dependable um sorry so you so so like if
you if you're an actor or a filmmaker or
both you want to be
Dependable to people you end up working
with but you don't want to be a people
pleaser what's an example of
each I think it it's the same thing it's
just doing what you love because the
thing is if you love doing something
you're going to do it people don't do
anything they don't want to do and they
only do what they have to do
well sometimes for a paycheck but they
have to do that they have to yeah so so
you're only going to do what you have to
do outside of that you're going to do
anything you don't want to do if you're
doing something you don't want to do
it's because you have to do it sure sure
you know what I mean how did you catch
yourself in being a people pleaser and
how did you change it I'm still doing it
man I'm still I'm still trying to get
over it you know you end up when you end
up in situations where you feel like you
want to work with people um you feel
like you're going to gain something out
of that situation you feel like you know
it's going to be mutually beneficial and
sometimes it is and sometimes it isn't
and sometimes you get in there and it's
just not working you know and and you
have to be able to say okay well it's
not it's not working like it's you got
you have to you have to take ownership
of your own life you have to take
ownership of what you're going to do
because what other people are going to
do that's what they're going to do it's
got nothing to do with you you know it
it really it really it really doesn't
you can only control what you are going
to do what you are capable of and what
you love so you might as well do the
thing you love because you know you're
going to do it and that makes you
dependable so if you're going to do it
cuz you love it you're going to run into
the people that love the same thing and
now it's mutually beneficial because
you're Dependable because you both love
the same thing but if I come to you you
and I say hey yeah I want to yeah come
on Karen we're going to do this thing
it's going to be awesome and you're like
yeah we're going to make the best sci-fi
horror thing ever and I'm like yeah and
then I go home God I hate sci-fi inor I
was gonna say that ha I can't stand it
but whatever Karen she knows some people
it's going to be awesome so I'm keep
doing
it it's not going to be the best that I
can do because I don't really like it
and you're G to be like um I don't think
this works and this works and this works
I mean like what the hell difference
does it make it's just sci-fi horror who
cares you just have to kill people in
space what's the big deal and you're
going be like I love
this now you tell me you now you've
wasted your time their time everybody's
upset you know what I mean right so you
don't do it you just do what you you do
the thing you think is awesome not the
thing you think is awesome or the thing
you think other people are going to find
awesome do what you think is awesome and
then the people that think that thing's
awesome will show up
too everybody thought Star Wars was
Psycho when they first did it we at it
now when you hear the phrase and forgive
me it I know this is kind of cliche but
like follow your dreams okay um does
that have the same meaning to you now as
it did when let's say your acting
teacher drove you down to LA from
fentura or early 20s yes it still does
absolutely okay
why I
think the biggest struggle is holding on
to that
feeling because when you don't know
anything it's all awesome you know what
I mean like you have no idea how the
business works you just know what you
want to do and so you go and you do it
and you're exuberant about it and you
love it and you do it all the time and
it's awesome and then you get into the
business and you start getting told no
they say no no no no and so then you
start going oh okay well this thing that
I really love and dig I should adjust it
I'm going to move it yeah I'll do this
cuz then I can get that no I better
change this thing around and then you're
not doing it because you love it you're
just you're just trying to win you know
what I mean I just need to win now once
I win
everything's and you lose sight of The
Passion of it
you know when you're a kid man you don't
think about okay well if we're going to
play cops and
robbers let's see am I the captain in
the office or or maybe I'm a lieutenant
are we undercover you don't think about
any of that it's coper robber you know
what I mean like I'm the cop you're the
robber it's fun and I think we lose
that because of the complexities of the
way the industry works and it's hard to
hold on to um
but yeah I I I I work my best to hold on
to that to that feeling um and it's why
I love writing so much because when
you're a writer you're just all by
yourself with your story you know and if
you can block out all the white noise of
people telling you what you should write
and you just write what you want to
write it's great man it's great you can
see it and you can feel it you get out
there and you're happy to deliver that
script to people and pass it around to
Representatives or producers or actors
or whoever you have access to to try to
get this thing happening and it's that's
the best so yeah you got to you got to
keep following you got to keep following
the
dream do you ever have trouble blocking
out time to write no you don't no I just
love writing it's is fun for me you know
some people like to go to bars
I like a glass of wine and a little Jazz
and I like to write um I know it's a
difficult thing I think it's a lot of
people I've spoken with it's daunting
for them to like stare at that blank
screen I started teaching um
screenwriting with a program called page
one toone um to help people because I
knew there were a lot of people that
were like going to these courses and
they buying these books and it seems to
me like I could be wrong but it seems to
me like the books almost make people
hesitant to write at all
um and my the my course um the goal is
to actually by the time it's over to
have a finished screenplay I get you
writing right
away just write you just it doesn't have
to be perfect like you don't have to you
don't have to have written Pulp Fiction
you know what I mean you're not going to
write Pulp Fiction you know you're going
to look at what you've written and
you're not going to like it that only
means that you've got excellent
excellent taste like you you you love
really great stuff
so you know you just have to start
anything and you'll get better at it um
and it's it's always hard to start so I
always tell people you remember when you
were a baby right so you were a baby and
you didn't know how to walk right so you
crawled right and then you finally got
up on your feet and then you fell so
what' you do probably cried yeah mhm did
you try it again well yeah obviously now
you're a professional right you can walk
you can walk in heels I bet even you
probably walk in heels backward You Can
Dance you can run that's like an
advanced walking technique you know what
I mean you just kept doing it that's all
it is you just keep doing it you just
keep doing it and you're going to get
better it's the law of averages you're
going to get better if you keep doing
something you
know script idea let's say you've seen
someone or something or an idea comes
into your head and you say I want to
write about that I want to finish 100
Pages what's your whole process from
page one to done to 99 yeah to done
there you go uh gosh this is going to
sound
terrible
um there are things you're supposed to
do as a writer that you should do um you
should make an outline you should make
your character breakdowns there's all
these things that you like do you make
your cards and you plot out your story
or first and second and third I don't do
any of that do none of it that's the
perfect screenwriter that's one that has
the folded sock drawer yes that's the
guy who does it all correctly I don't do
any of that I like to sit and think
about the idea and then I like to think
about the character who that woman or
man is and what they're like and what
their world looks like and then I just
start to think about what the movie
might look like in my head and once I
sort of start seeing the movie itself in
my head head then I start writing it I
don't know how it's going to end
necessarily unless it's a thriller if
it's a thriller I need to know how it's
going to end so I can know where I got
to go if that makes sense you know
because you always want to have that
ending that people go so you think of
the ending first like what would be a
cool and then oh okay now how do I get
there so I go backward if it's a
thriller if it's not a thriller if it's
just a story about people and life and
love or whatever it is then I don't
really think that much about what's
going to happen I just sort of think
about the people and where they are and
where I want them to be what the world's
like what they enjoy there's usually a
lot of wine involved because I enjoy
some wine um and uh what happens is I
end up writing I
think something that's much more uh
organic and much more um
here I am a writer and I can't find a
word uh what is the word organic
and what is it what's what's the word
when something just spontaneous
spontaneous organic I end up writing
something that's more organic and
spontaneous because I haven't sort of
telegraphed it and kind of like when
you're acting you know you always hear
don't play result you know because you
read the entire script so your character
is on a journey so you know what that
journey is but the character doesn't
know so you don't want to play like you
know what's coming because you'll
telgraph it to the
audience I find the same thing works for
me as a writer by not knowing everything
when I'm writing I'm discovering it as
I'm writing and it makes the writing
process exciting for me because I'm like
sitting there at the keyboard I'm like
this is great you know people like
what's going to happen next I don't know
I can't wait to find out either you know
what I mean it's like it's a spontaneous
thing um and then hopefully the training
and and and the laws of inevitability
that I try to keep focused in my head
you know kick in as I'm writing and when
it's done it's it's a really great it's
a really great story but yeah I I I I I
like to look at it as a living breathing
story that's unfolding as if I'm
watching it um
and that drives me toward the end
because I feel like if I do all the
outline stuff for me if I do all the
outline stuff I've already kind of done
it already so now I was like ah now I
got to write it all I did all the I
already figured it out so I just like to
jump in and start
writing because you've been in front of
the camera and you've seen how all this
works as an actor do you have a better
idea or do you approach it in a
different way than maybe people that
have never been on that side of the
camera
probably for writing scripts yeah I
think so I mean you know because I'm I'm
looking
at I I try to write things I I would
want to say you know and I try to write
things I think actors would want to say
so in that regard I think there's a
little bit of an advantage but you know
people come up to me all the time like
oh my God I don't know how to write like
well you don't know how to write cuz you
just said you don't know how to write
you know what none of us realize is that
we've all been studying film for decades
like when how old were you when you saw
your first movie well the one that
stands out is probably ET or Kramer
versus Kramer and so you were like how
old uh I was young you were young you're
a young girl right and so now you're a
grown woman yes so you've been watching
movies for longer than it takes for a
doctor to become a doctor oh absolutely
yeah but I remember Kramer versus Kramer
just just loving that film seeing it and
and just resonating with the film and
and see that's exactly my point you know
what you like you know why you like it
and you know why you don't like what you
don't
like right true so if you want to be a
doctor where you go to four years of
college right and then you do four years
of med school right and then you do like
what you do like an
internship you do like a residency and
then you're a doctor so what is that
like 12 years it's a long time right but
you've been watching movies for longer
than 12 years than that yeah yeah see
that's what I'm saying I told you that
all the time nobody realizes that you've
been watching them a lot longer I don't
necessarily think there's intricacies to
the industry that people that are
Executives and producers and all that
they know that the audience doesn't know
but in terms of what makes a movie Click
I don't think they know any better than
we do right I don't think they know they
act like they know cuz they got these
articles about what you're supposed to
say and all of that stuff but they're
all looking for the thing that's going
to work they're all looking for it you
know what I mean and I think if you've
been watching movies all that time you
just take the time to sort of focus on
that and realize how much you actually
know and then you read some scripts get
your hands on some scripts they got this
thing called the internet now anybody
can get their hands on the script now
right and we're past dial up yeah man
yeah exactly
I you know there yeah yes there's a
definite advantage of being in the
business and understanding it and
knowing it but we can't talk down to the
audience they've been watching films for
decades they know what's
up what film changed your life or role
not that you were in one you saw one
that I saw well first
one first one was
um Vinnie
barbarino I wanted to be Vinnie bar
arino I wanted to be John Travolta and
welcome back cter I was like oh my God
how cool is that guy um and then I and
that's how I found out that acting was
actually a job he wasn't just super cool
and somebody found out and just started
following him around in his real life
and that's when I thought yeah dude I
want to be like that I want to be like
that so hopefully one day I can meet by
Vinnie
barbarino I think John trol is a cool
enough guy that if I say can I meet
Vinnie barbarino he'll give me a little
Vinnie barbarino and staying alive and
staying alive and all that stuff but
yeah it was it was definitely seeing
that um but movie
wise probably uh the precursor to me
wanting to be a filmmaker before I even
understood that I wanted to be a
filmmaker was seeing crimes and
misdemeanors by Woody Allen you know I
just thought
how cool is this there's like two movies
happening at one time that's insane like
i' had never seen that before I was a
little kid you know but still I was like
there's two movies there's like this
movie with this guy and he's in love
with this girl and the girl's in love
with the douchebag and then there's this
other movie where this guy's looking to
kill another he's trying to kill this
crazy two movies at once it's awesome so
I love that
um and I think there's an old movie
1937 it's called stage door and it's a
wonderful film about a bunch of women
who live in a boarding house they're
actresses they used to put actresses in
boarding homes back in the day um and
stars Katherine heurn
and Ginger Rogers and a dramatic Lucio
ball before she was redhead it's amazing
love love love love that movie I'm
awesome so probably those three sort of
changed me we were talking earlier about
John Updike I know it's weird I must
have been like channeling your love for
him because I was for some reason just
watching all these videos with him
yesterday um doing a bunch of work and
he both John Updike and Joyce Carol OES
have both said that a writer's
imagination usually comes from being
more isolated as a
child and because they're
alone that they come up with these
elaborate stories in their mind that
would be true in my case okay that would
be true in my case I am the youngest of
I'm the youngest um my my my brother is
15 years older than me and my sister's
11 years older than me so I was all by
myself making up stuff in my head all
the time so yes I would agree with John
Updike he's John Updike I probably agree
with whatever he
said but that we we get into that that
mindset all the time and we're just
always you know I mean I spend a lot of
time alone too so it's just always
imagining things and that's how we
entertain ourselves and we never grow
out of it I think that's why I love
writing so much so I'm all by myself
making up stories it would I used to be
in a place where I would be writing all
day and I get out of the room and I'd
walk around and I would be very confused
because people would be talking but I
didn't write that I didn't write those
words they're not supposed to talk it
took me a while to sort of adjust
because I get so used to creating
my own world I would walk out of my room
and somebody say hey Marcus what's up
I'd be like why are you talking I didn't
write that I didn't write you're not
supposed to even be here like what so
yeah I I would I would get completely
lost in these people in these stories I
still do I just can manage it better now
so I don't look at people weird because
people have their own brains they can
say things that I didn't write it's
perfectly fine do you feel most safe
behind that computer creating that world
and they were talking about too just you
can create whatever like life is one you
know sort of boring existence but then
these stories that you can create is a
whole another realm I think I know Woody
Allen in um deconstructing Harry you
know he he he his character liked he was
a writer and he he would write he
couldn't function in life but he could
fix it in fiction um so I think there's
definitely an element of that to what I
like to do I don't know if it's safety
that I feel um I definitely look forward
to getting out from behind the computer
to make the movies
um but it's definitely comfortable it's
definitely comfortable I do love when I
have the time and I'm not busy you know
directing and producing and doing all
the stuff intrinsic to that and I can
just
write I do love it I do love it it's a
great place to be to just sit and listen
to music and
write in order to survive the movie
business long term um how essential is
it for an actor to also write direct and
produce like you're
doing um to keep that career going in my
opinion incredibly
essential acting is a tough gig man it's
hard I have so much respect for my
friends that are actors and they have
representatives and they go out on those
auditions but you're waiting for
somebody to pick
you it's tough It's just tough you know
you're waiting for somebody to pick you
so that they can tell their
vision and I know people that make a lot
of money and they're doing something you
know on television or in film they make
a ton of
money but they're
bored
really because they're just not enjoying
the stories that are out there play the
same character S 8 nine 10 years you
know you're making a ton of money but
you're not really you don't feel
creative anymore you know and it's
like and then the problem with that
especially if it's in television is you
do TV and you do a show and it lasts 10
years and then it's over and then you go
off and you're like all right I'm free I
want to do this and they go no but you
look guy from that show so we don't want
the guy from that show in our film it's
like now you're that guy you know how
long do you have to be that guy before
people realize you're not that guy
that's a madeup guy and you can do other
things it's tough It's very very tough
what I learned or discovered in
writing was that I could create my own
vision and I could take full
responsibility for it
and I could create whatever I wanted to
create now that comes with disadvantages
you know money does not going to come
first when you do it that way you're
going to be up against different
obstacles but they're all obstacles like
it's either I'm either trying to find a
way to make it work for a little bit of
money or I'm sitting around staring at a
phone that's not ringing they're both
hard you know but the end game is what I
think you always have to be mindful of
like what do you want and I think if you
really want to show your artistic
nature and you really want to showcase
yourself in the best light and what you
do well I
think you know get out there and make
your own stuff and if you don't have
that if you don't feel like you have
that then like you know team up with
people that do and and and make a team
and you know the three four four or five
of you together create something that's
uniquely your own the tribe find the
tribe yeah find your folks go find your
folks it's hard you know there's people
out there that have been represented for
years and they haven't worked there's
people out there that are brilliant they
don't have representation it's very
difficult
but anybody can post stuff on
YouTube anybody can go on Twitter and
start building an audience for
themselves
and now apparently they're looking for
that I just read a thing the other day
casting directors they care more about
your Twitter following than they do
about your
talent you know if you're an actor
that's like getting punched in the balls
you know what I mean it's terrible but
it's a reality of how it works so how do
you combat how do you do that how do you
combat that like how do you become the
guy that's got enough Twitter followers
if you're sitting around waiting for
your phone to ring and you're waiting
for somebody to pick you you got to
start doing something you got to get up
and do it it's different it's a
different world you used to be able to
like pitch and weight you could go in
and be like this is great oh yeah it
sounds awesome here's a check let's see
how it turns out those days are gone
those days are gone you can buy a camera
that can
create visuals that can be put on a
screen theatrically and it'll cost you
two grand people are out there shooting
movies man it's about shooting show
now money doesn't come first now now you
got to show what you can do you got to
go out there you got to shoot something
and make it great for nothing and then
say here's what I did so that you're not
saying we have a lot of interest you
want to be you got to show people like
what do you do what's your latest script
latest script check out my flick look at
the movie whoa yeah and what do you
think I could do if I had 10 grand more
50 Grand more 100 Grand more shoo and
show what have you learned as the
biggest uh some of the biggest budget
wasters because you know you're talking
about some of the the budgets you were
working with and uh where have
you kind of rained back you know my
budgets are so
tiny not a whole lot to waste on mine um
but I think I think
the best
thing the best thing the be the hardest
thing is time managing the time you know
because when you're doing something for
so little everybody's got to love it
it's got to be about passion but you
also can't sit around wasting your time
you can't waste their time people are
coming to you and they're bringing you
great stuff so you can make this movie
you owe it to them to know what the hell
you're doing at least know what the hell
you want you can't sit around be like I
don't know should I shoot the I
know prepare know what you want you know
Woody Allen says if you're the writer of
the story you already know what you want
the audience to
see so as a director I try to figure
that out know what it is when people
come in we hit the ground running not
here to waste your time I'm here to
facilitate you having fun and having
your passion get displayed so let's get
to it let's make it happen let's do it
it and then you can go home and pet your
cat do whatever you do come back we'll
do it again later but yeah timing really
timing giving people the time to do what
they do best but not wasting time trying
to figure out how it's going to do do
all that work ahead of
time what's been the most helpful
resource or like a creative tool is
there a a book um an annual event a
class that stands out as like either you
continually turn to it or that was
really a turning point aside from the
acting class of course that that really
sounds like it just they just believed
in you and they it was really good the
films and documentaries that I've seen
from Woody Allen episodes of
Taxi the music of Arty Shaw Benny
Goodman Glenn
Miller and Roy
Eldridge red
wine
and my production team verita Irvin and
Brooks Kart and James
Lang
and my friend Drew Mouser who kept
yelling at me to direct and shut up
about complaining uh and my wife my wife
Isis those were the best tools that I
had and I turn to them time and time
again there's a there's there's a
two-part documentary on Woody Allen I
probably watch it three or four times a
month really I I I search my uh I search
my DVR for old episodes of taxi to get
inspiration I listen to uh that good old
stuff cuz it reminds me of my dad and
all the stuff that he dug and those
sensibilities stick with me um and my
buddy my my my great friend Alicia muu
who I write for very much um so great
great resource she's a wonderful actress
and she's a huge support huge part of my
support system um so yeah those those
are the things that I I turn to all the
time she reads just about everything I
write and uh yeah I just I just keep it
moving I'm always writing since not
everybody has a support system or maybe
it's a well-intentioned support system
but it's doesn't work right so where
would they find their own ways to plug
into something if they don't want to
glob on to a group they don't want to be
sort of parasitic in that way but then
they want to find what they love how do
they
know it's tough man that's a tough
question how do you find what you love
and how do you be your own support
system I think you be your own support
system by figuring out what you
love I think you find what you love
by opening yourself
up and giving
yourself
permission to love whatever you want to
love a lot of times it's hard cuz
people don't really think they deserve
something that's their own or they feel
like other people need to come first or
they feel like people are depending on
them so they have to be all these other
things but the thing
is you're you you're either a man or a
woman
and in order for you to be all these
other things you got to feed that man or
that woman
first and you don't necessarily need to
know exactly what it is you just have to
allow yourself the permission to be open
to it who knows what it could be it
could be
anything but give yourself permission to
let it
come you know and and when it does come
and you feel it
man grab on to it make it your own don't
let anybody tell you you're stupid don't
let anybody tell you you're not supposed
to don't let anybody tell you that's not
how it's done nobody knows what they're
talking about nobody knows what they're
talking about everybody's just trying to
figure out how to do it you know what I
mean your way isn't any better or any
worse than anybody else's it's just
yours so
just find your stuff man and love it who
cares as long as you're you do what you
do and you got a smile on your
face who cares what anybody else thinks
who cares doesn't matter just do what
you love it'll come you allow it to come
it'll come that's what I think
anyway
yeah
brownies brownies are always good they
[Laughter]
help